[Musique]
bon rien tu es un menteur
on peut jamais de faire confiance en le
bac c'est pas la peine d'y penser c'est
pas fait pour toi tu feras jamais rien
dans la vie tu finiras lusine voilà ce
qu'il entend tous les jours il en
quatrième vient de partir en vrille
ces notes se sont écroulées j'ai
commencé à faire quelques bêtises
pourquoi le divorce de ses parents
les absences à la maison les mauvaises
rencontres
certainement un peu tout ça rapidement
j'ai retrouvé dans la case des mauvais
élèves alors des conneries il en a fait
plus de plus en plus et plus en plus
grosse en est à l'école n'en faisait
moins de moins en moins ne faisait plus
rien ils ont raison il devient celui qui
le décrivent tous les jours en ce gamin
ça aurait pu être certains d'entre vous
mais ça a été moi et puis à 16 ans deux
choses m'ont fait basculer les
découvertes lors de mon premier emploi
saisonnier d'une réalité celle que
vivent des millions de personnes qui
travaillent à l'usiné vers 16 heures son
boulot s'éteindre de jour en jour pour
attendre la retraite
le rev 1 et puis il m'a tendu d'un
inconnu
celle du directeur du lycée de la salle
à rennes lui ne jugez pas les gens sur
leur passé il voulait juste faire
grandir les jeunes leur donner une
chance aux ap un truc de dingue juste
pouvoir faire un bep commerce 1 alors à
la rentrée j'avais nouvelles chansons
c'est un nouveau départ
j'avais envie de lui démontrer qu'il
avait eu raison de me faire confiance
ans et j'ai eu ma première note
c'était un 12 ans j'étais fier comme un
coq mes parents aussi une vraie base
courant
et là j'ai dit j'ai découvert une prof
incroyable mariannick mariannick et
n'était pas comme les autres elle nous
écoutait nous acceptait comme on était
vous pouvez changer
on avait le droit de mettre d'accord et
voulait emmener tout le monde et nous
faisait confiance nous confier des
projets étaient toujours disponibles
sa porte était toujours ouverte après
les cours mais aussi chez elle et on a
découvert sa famille et on est devenu
une grande famille
et là je découvrais qu'on pouvait faire
grandir les gens en étant sympa avec eux
du coup vrai que tous les profs
n'étaient pas comme ceux du collège m a
motivé ma transformer n'a donné envie
j'ai eu mon bep assez facilement et pour
mes parents pour moi mais aussi pour
elle
j'ai eu envie d'aller plus loin alors je
me suis lancée vers le bac
bon juste un bac professionnel faut pas
abuser non plus sur entrée dans le monde
professionnel par un stage on me faisait
confiance en blanc il fallait être à la
hauteur et j'ai été à la hauteur puisque
comme embauchés pendant ce stage j'ai
arrêté l'école en jeu pas c'est bon je
m'étais engagé à passer mon bac en
candidat libre
alors tous les jours je travaillais et
le soir jusqu'à 23h avec le drh de
l'entreprise
je préparais mon bac c'était l'école
dans l'entreprise
j'ai eu mon bac j'étais heureux j'avais
respecter la parole donnée à mon père je
n'avais plus qu'une chose à faire un
m'éclater professionnellement j'ai grave
les échelons un à un mais j'étais
commercial chef de publicité directeur
d'agencé et là j'ai découvert le
management temps c'était mon rêve en
finalement j'ai détesté ça la première
année c'était horrible je rentrais à la
maison j'ai dit à ma femme c'est pas le
métier que je veux faire c'était mieux
avant maintenant je n'ai que des
emmerdes
et puis je me suis posée j'ai réfléchi
et j'ai repensé à mariannick sa façon
d'emmener tout le monde de faire
confiance en de faire grandir un savez
marché pour moi pourquoi ça marcherait
pas pour les autres
et finalement on s'est éclatés et sa
super bien marché pendant huit ans et
puis le blouson le gros coup de bambou
je vais pas ce qui m'arrivait j'étais
pas bien
- la pêche - l'envi tellement j'étais
mal
j'ai même failli refuser la main qui
m'était tendu et pourtant quelle
occasion
on me proposait de créer la filiale
internet du groupe alors que je n'y
connaissais rien du tout sur internet
je me suis lancé j'ai embauché 20
personnes puis 40 ans on a pris tous
ensemble
la magie a opéré le succès commercial le
champagne toutes les semaines nous
avancions à toute vitesse
nous étions une start up dans un grand
groupe et là j'étais confronté à une
autre réalité celle des grands groupes
trente sept réunions par semaine
les guerres internes les jalousies les
non-décisions on commençait même à
laisser des gens sur le bas côté
ça n'était pas ma philosophie
je suis en train de me perdre un alors
deux chemins possibles rentrer dans le
moule et me renier ou tout larguer et
bien j'ai tranché
j'ai tout larguer sauf ma femme mes
enfants et mon chien je rêvais devenir
entrepreneur finalement ce problème est
un cadeau et là une autre main tendue
celle de david sans qui je n'aurais
jamais pu monter le projet de ma vie je
suis hyper motivé je me lance à fond et
je rachète mediaveil en six semaines
en six ans nous passons de 10 à 110
collaborateurs
aujourd'hui les résultats sont là mais
ce qui me fait le plus plaisir c'est
juste de voir mon équipe se dire bonjour
le matin par des tchèques des accolades
ou des bisous me fait un bien fou et me
dit que ce que nous vivons est juste bon
pour les gens qu'ils sont jeunes ils
vivent un truc de dingue pour beaucoup
leur première expérience
pour les autres une plus belle
expérience et pour moi sans nul doute la
plus belle
et puis il ya deux ans un simple coup de
fil à transpercer mon coeur je suis face
à une autre réalité celle d'un père qui
aurait pu être moi
confrontés au handicap de sa fille
alexia à 17 ans la médecine lui découvre
une maladie orpheline
elle me raconte son quotidien ses
contraintes physiques
elle est dans l'obligation d'abandonner
sa scolarité elle est reconnue jeunes
adultes handicapés touche 700 euros par
mois
la société ne lui doit plus rien ce
n'est pas ce qu'elle cherche
elle veut vivre et pour vivre
elle veut juste un travail j'ai fait la
promesse à son père que je lui donnerai
le coup de main malgré toutes nos
démarches
les portes ne s'ouvrent pas alexia ne
connaît pas nos métiers mais je
l'embauchant nous allons la forme et je
me rappellerai toute ma vie du coup de
fil de son père fou de joie qui me dit
olivier tu te rends compte de ce que tu
fais mais alexia va plus se lever le
matin pour sa maladie va se lever le
matin pour aller au boulot y retrouver
des collègues
que voulez vous faire après ça et bien
moi j'ai juste eu envie d'en faire un
peu plus j'ai tendu une main alexia mais
il me reste une alors par un après-midi
de printemps je rentre au bureau je
croise isabelle un autre responsable
formation et je dis ça j'ai une idée qui
va te sembler un peu folle ans mais j'ai
envie j'ai envie de créer une école une
école différente en une école dans
l'entreprise une école qui donne sa
chance en nicole qui met pas les gens
dans des cases
une école qui tend la main et qui
formant aux métiers de demain et les
conquise immédiatement par l'idée est ni
une ni deux nous nous lançons dans
l'aventuré et découvrons la joie des
démarches administratives
tout le monde trouve l'idée formidable
tout le monde nous propose de faire des
réunions mais il ne se passe rien hélas
la situation se débloque grâce à marilyn
la directrice de l'ime le dossier ce
montant les démarches avançant le projet
devient super participatif et en juillet
2016 nous obtenons l'accord nous allons
pouvoir former 15 personnes
la formation sera réservé un public
prioritaire des gens au chômage en
situation de handicap ou non diplômés
elle se déroulera sur 10 mois six mois
de cours
quatre mois de stage elle sera
totalement prise en charge pour les
élèves et avec un objectif ultime leur
trouver du job à tout ça et là la magie
opère trente huit de mes collaborateurs
se porte candidat pour devenir formateur
il rédige l'intégralité du programme 20
dirigeants d'entreprise se proposant
spontanément d'intervenir gratuitement
en courant nous agrandissons les locaux
nous faisons les travaux nous aménageons
la classe et oui il faut bien une classe
dans une école là
pouvons enfin lancé l'appel aux
candidats en un mois des appels dans
tous les sens en tous les jours nous
recevons 300 candidatures et le 3
octobre en 2016 c'est le grand jour
nous pouvons lancer officiellement
l'école digital de la nouvelle chanson
quelle leçon de vie pour moi ce premier
jour voir face à nous ces 15 personnes
ne se présentait une à une toutes au
chômage en deux en situation de handicap
un certaine bien diplômés d'autres ans
sans aucun diplôme en onze femmes quatre
hommes
j'avais conscience des difficultés de
certaines personnes mais franchement pas
ce point là je pense est une élève 26
ans bac + 5
les portes ne se sont jamais ouverte 1
elle n'a jamais pu travailler depuis
quatre ans elle est au chômage et sans
se rendre compte en sa famille ses amis
lui mettre la pression
juste en lui demandant si elle a des
nouvelles ou si elle a des pistes qui au
fur et à mesure et sait plus quoi leur
répondre en aveu - les voir elle va -
les voir en essais le début de l'
isolement et là je me rends compte que
finalement moi aussi je mettais les gens
dans des cases la case des gens qui
veulent pas bosser mais la réalité c'est
pas ça
cette école c'est une main tendue pour
leur donner de l'espoir à leur donner
confiance en confiance en eux confiance
en nous confiance dans notre société
leur donner envie de se lever le matin
pour aller au boulot apprendre en
retrouver des collègues retrouver une
vie sociale vivre tout simplement
quel bonheur pour moi des croisés et de
voir leurs yeux briller leurs têtes se
relever cette école m'a permis aussi de
mieux découvrir un les gens qui
m'entourent
mon équipe sans qui ce projet n'aurait
jamais pu aboutir
hilarant du concret les valeurs humaines
qu on partage tous les jours ensemble en
n'imaginez pas le bonheur que je peux
avoir en a travaillé à leurs côtés tous
les jours la fierté que j'ai mais cette
école en ceci une source de frustration
quinze élèves 300 candidats ses 285
personnes que nous n'avons pas pu aider
une autre source de frustration que je
l'avais pas imaginer c'est l'étiquette
qui peut être collée sur la tête des
élèves en des élèves de la nouvelle
chanson mais en dehors de ça
cette école si une source d'espoir
incroyable pour le futur
j'ai été contacté par des gens du monde
entier de suisse de tunisie du maroc de
paris de saint malo pour monter le même
type de projets dans leur ville rien que
sur rennes l'année prochaine
trois projets similaires sont en cours
de création
et si nous étions en train de bâtir un
nouveau modèle de formation de
transmission des savoirs ans et si dans
les années futures
nous passions de 15 à 15 milles ce
projet c'est le projet professionnel qui
me rapporter les plus grandes émotions
et plus belles satisfactions qui m'aura
fait le plus grand d'iran et toucher du
doigt les valeurs humaines qui peuvent
nous entourer ce gamin dont je vous ai
parlé
ça a été moi mais ça aurait pu être vous
des mains tendues
vous en avez eu vous les avez vu ou pas
vous les avez saisies ou pas mais soyez
attentifs vous en aurez d'autres et
elles peuvent changer vos vies imaginez
le monde que nous pourrions construire
ensemble en ces vies que nous pourrions
changer si nous apprenions juste une
chose en apprendre attendre nos mains
alors pour ces gamins pour vous pour eux
je vous invite à vous lever et attendre
vos mains merci pour eux
[Applaudissements]